اهلا فيكم مشاهدينا اذا الليله كانت بشعه
وحزينه جدا على اهالي الدقهليه في مصر
بسبب جريمه شنيعه جدا انتشرت اخبارها
عربيه وعلى كل المنصات الجنين ارتكبها
الزوج ذبح زوجته وتصور مع الجثه سلفي
وارسلها لعائلتها بحسب وسائل الاعلام ومن
بعدها اخرجي مقاطع نشرها على حساباته
بطالب فيه بحضور الاعلام لحتى يخبرهم بشو
صار
انا مش هنزل من فوق من شقتي
ويعرف ايه اللي وصلنا ويعرف انا في الوضع
ده
كل ده من اجل ثلاث بنات نفسي اكون معهم في
الدنيا ثلاث بنات بتمنى ان اكون معهم في
الدنيا سواء حلوه هو وحش قوي
انا مش هانزل من شقتي بعيالي الا لما يجي
قنوات تصور معي عشان الناس تعرف حقيقته
اسمه حماده العجوز متزوج من زينب اللي كان
عمرها 26 سنه لديهم معن ثلاث بنات اكبرهم
تسع سنوات واصغرهم ثلاث سنوات اتزوج
والزوجه منفصلين من ثلاث سنوات
وقال انه زوجته
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل في كل واحد شارك انه بعدنا عن
اطفال ذهبيه حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل في الظالم
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل في الظالم اللي كان
جاي يشاركها في قتل النهارده وعايز يبعدنا
عن عيالي حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل والله
وبعدين
المصريه في بيان القبض على الزوج وكشفت
التفاصيل قالت انه الاجهزه الامنيه سيطره
طبعا هو كان محتجز بناته في بلكونه وهدد
بقتلهم وقال انه تعدى على زوجته بسبب
خلافات زوجه
طبعا الشرطه في المسكن عليها وفيها جرح
قطع في الرقبه والسلاح الابيض ايضا
المستخدم في الجريمه
مشاهدينا من الدقهليه ابراهيم فرج ناصف
والد الضحيه زينب وسامح سمير محامي
العائله اهلا فيكم معنا في تفاعلكم بدايه
ببدا معكم استاذ ابراهيم تعزينا الحاره
طبعا على فقدان زينب جريمه بشعه جدا واحنا
متفهمين طبعا ظروف العائله وموقفكم الان
ولكن حابين نفهم الحكايه من الاول ايه
اللي حصل بالضبط هي زينب كانت منفصله عنه
اللي يعني رجعها له بعد قبل اسبوع تقريبا
بعد ثلاث سنوات من الانفصال
الله قبل ما يمشي
بعد سنه ونصف في السعوديه
وامراتك اهي يابا ومش عاوزين حد يضحك
علينا قال لك خلاص
يابانيه
حضن واحد غير جوزي
قالها بدل الجوازه
واولاد الثلاث بنات
جبت لهم وترواهم 24
ايه اللي خلاه يعمل اللي عمله ويقتل زينب
هو بيقول بانه هي كانت متفقه مع حد عشان
تتخلص منه الكلام ده مضبوط
وقوم بدل الواحد بدل المره 3 4 5
قامت قالت يا باشا
الفيديو قلت لهم لا ما شفتوش الفيديو
كده انت بتستهبلي ده زينب امبارح الساعه
10:00 بالليل وكويسه
اللي هنا المباحث واقفه
اسمح لي استاذ ابراهيم راح نرجع لهذا
الموضوع خليني اتكلم شويه مع الاستاذ سامح
استاذ سامح طبعا تم اعتقال
الجاني في هذه القضيه زوج زينب لوين وصلت
التحقيقات وهل هناك اي معلومات حول شو
الدافع للجريمه همم يعني اذا كان طبعا اهل
الضحيه عم بيقولوا انهم يعني هذا الكلام
عن انها عشان تتخلص منه مع اي شخص اخر
عاري عن الصحه تماما هل كان بكامل قوى
العقليه ماذا
لا طبعا سياده الكوره اللي ارحب بحضرتك
والقناه العربيه
وحب اوضح نقاط
التحقيقات النيابه نفسها يعني
الكلام ده عالي جدا من الصحه اولا الولد
ده كان في كامل قوات العقليه الولد ده كان
مدبر مخطط
وعازم النيه وفي ادله بتؤكل كده وده اللي
نسبته قدام النيابه العامه نيابه طلخا
سيادتك
القصه دلوقت اللي هي البنت اللي الله
يرحمها زينب
[موسيقى]
كانت منفصله عن زوجها سنه ونصف ولا سنتين
دخلت في سنتين
التالي
عيالها ثلاث بنات عندها ثلاث بنات
او الدافع قيل بانه كان تحت تاثير
المخدرات هل تحقيق
لا لسه طبعا التحقيقات لان طبعا المتهم
بيتعرض على الطب الشرعي وبيتم تحليله
بنسبه التحليلات اذا كان تحت تاثير المخدر
ولا لا بس انا عايز اقول لسيادتك حاجه من
الفيديوهات اللي سيادتك عرضتيها من شويه
فيديوهات من النظر اليها بالعين المجرده
بيبين ان الشخص مدرب
وعرفه هو بيعمل ايه كويس شخص طبيعي جدا
يعني
استاذ ابراهيم هو يعني
يبدو انه شخص طبيعي ولكن في ذات الوقت
الافعال لا تنوم على انه شخص طويل طيب
استاذ ابراهيم انا بس حابه اسالك قبل ما
كان في حديث كثير عن انه هو مش بس نشر
هذول الفيديوهات اللي نشرها مش بس نشر
فيديوهات على حساباته ولكن بعثت لك انت
شخصيا الفيديو للاسف يعني متصور هو سلفي
مع جثه زينب مضبوط الكلام ده بعث لك فيديو
هو
ايوه بقى كله
الفيديو اهو يعني هو نشر على حساباتهم
استاذ ابراهيم
انت مروحين وكلاب
[موسيقى]
مع حد يابا انا موجود يا بنت
رايحه فرحانه
البنت يوم الاربعاء
يوم الاحد
العيد
نتمنى تحقيق العداله اكيد استاذ ابراهيم
زينب يرجع باذن الله ما في كلام حكى يعني
الله يرحمها استاذ ابراهيم ويصبركم يا رب
سامح سمير محامي العائله شكرا
مشاهدينا كاميرا تفاعلكم كانت في موقع
الجريمه وسمعت لبعض الجيران جيران الضحيه
خلونا نتابع
تني
بدانا نتكلم واولادك
عباره عن ايه هل ان هو
نعرفه ان هو بيشرب وهي معترض بيشرب مخدرات
رجع بقى له اربع ايام من يوم الاربعاء وهي
راجعه
رجعت الاخ ان وهي على سريرها ذبحها
الله اعلم السبب ايه واحده راجعه بقى لها
اربع ايام في الفيديو بتاعه اللي هيتكلم
انه يتعاطى او ناحيه المخدرات استحاله
تكون رجل الفيديو كويس تلاقوه بيتكلم
بمنتهى العقلانيه
[موسيقى]